una sequía que podría ser la peor de los
últimos 500 años
por supuesto italia se encuentra entre
los países más afectados por la actual
sequía así como el sur de francia
grandes áreas de españa y portugal el
sur y este de alemania y una gran parte
de rumanía hungría y ucrania
frente a la falta prolongada de lluvias
que vive actualmente europa el centro
común de investigación de la comisión
europea anunció sus predicciones para el
continente bay son deleites de edad we
just the risk y basándonos en los
últimos datos que acabamos de recibir
hemos calculado esta mañana que la
superficie bajo condiciones de
advertencia por sequía es
aproximadamente el 47% del total de las
tierras europeas presentes de todas
también europea nadando en el reino
unido- la hierba seca del parque
londinense de greenwich hace eco de la
alerta ámbar que declaró la oficina
meteorológica para esta semana mientras
inglaterra se preparaba para otra ola de
calor lo que llevó el mayor proveedor de
agua del país a anunciar nuevas
restricciones de consumo y del lado de
francia los árboles sufren tanto de la
falta de agua y del exceso de calor
arbour y cultores temen tener que dar
por perdida una parte de su producción
el árbol cuando hace mucho calor ya no
se alimenta cierra sus esto más que lo
que le permite respirar y hacer la
fotosíntesis y descansa si descansa ya
no alimenta su fruto y si le falta agua
igualmente el fruto no se alimenta
adecuadamente por lo que perjudica su
crecimiento
en la agricultura como en el turismo las
repercusiones de la sequía están
alterando el verano europeo
el centro común de investigación de la
comisión europea ayer tuvo que si no se
toman medidas efectivas de mitigación
las áreas afectadas por la falta de agua
aumentarán tanto en el norte como en el
sur del continente